foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight on Facebook when I censor two
blonde Bombshells bunker down to fight
for their political lives Boris Johnson
insists he didn't lie to MPS over
lockdown parties that broke his own laws
but as his own loyalists gear him on
live TV is Teflon Boris finally done
we'll debate
name on America former president Donald
Trump sensation he faces criminal
indictment over harsh money he paid to
the porn star Stormy Daniels so is
Teflon Don also toast I'll ask his top
advisor kellyanne Conway
and that other favorite of this show
Prince Harry's US Visa is under scrutiny
off he boasted about drug use in America
in his Memoir on TV interviews but
Britain doesn't want him back so where
will he go we'll discuss that
[Music]
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening uh welcome to Facebook
and I sent it I'm back uh flew in this
morning from America more of that later
in the program Donald Trump and Boris
Johnson a lot in common they're both
populist Leaders with shocking blonde
hairdos who are big on bravado and
famously economical with the truth they
both command cut like devotion from
their Loyalists and blame shadowy
elitist plots for self-inflicted chaos
and tonight they're both fighting for
their political lies Donald Trump faces
criminal charges over hush money
payments to the porn star Stormy Daniels
next week America is brace for chaos
amid the unprecedented spectacle of a
former president hauled in for
fingerprinting and yes a mug shot
today in the UK the unprecedented
spectacle of a former British prime
minister defending the indefensible in a
televised Showdown with the Privileges
committee
we'll be out in terms of va yes I swear
by almighty God that the evidence I
shall give for this committee should be
the truthful truth and nothing but the
truth so help me God well that will
certainly make a change won't it Boris
uh but there was an extraordinary
spectacle today and let's be honest he's
finally come clean about misleading MPS
over Downing Street parties which broke
the lockdown laws he imposed on the
country he led but he shamefully took
him six months to do that and in vintage
Boris style and he traces of Contrition
were eclipsed by a volley of feeble
excuses which laid the blame squarely of
course on everybody other than him
I want to dispute the idea that it was
not an essential Gathering or not a
gathering that was reasonably necessary
for work purposes
people who say that we were partying in
lockdown simply do not know what they
are talking about
the people who say that that event was a
purely social Gathering are quite wrong
my my purpose there was to thank staff
to motivate them in what had been a very
difficult time
really really Boris you want us to
swallow that one
attending boozy parties dozens of you on
occasions while the rest of the country
was abiding by the strict rules Udall
made
that people couldn't even go and see
dying relatives in hospital while you
look we're all toasting each other and
having farewell parties
even borrows his own most strident
supporters aren't buying it anymore
you can't
um you can't expect uh human beings in
an environment like number 10
to have as it were a
um
invisible electrified fence around them
they will occasionally drift into each
other's orbit that I knew from my direct
personal experience that we were doing a
huge amount to stop the spread of covid
within the building
bound to say that if you'd said all that
at the time to the House of Commons we
probably wouldn't be sitting here
but you did well quite Boris blusted
through several hours of evidence today
following the release of a 52-page dodgy
dossier trademark dithering and
deception which is heavy on excuses
light on plausible explanation he whines
and he was photographed toasting
colleagues at a birthday party but
nobody sang Happy Birthday or served him
a cake he blames his advisor Dominic
Cummings for smearing him he blames the
small size of his home and offers it
down the street forcing people to work
in close proximity no word on why they
needed to be in close proximity to
suitcases of wine he blames the police
for not clarifying which rules he broken
even though he literally set the rules
for everybody else to follow
fifteen thousand words and this
supposedly named clearing dossier but
the two words I'm sorry weren't among
them despite being the only ones and
British people frankly want to hear and
the only person Boris hasn't blamed is
the one person who's really responsible
for all this and that's the boss which
was him
well joining me now I've talked to these
political editors except you can okay
um I watched a lot of this today I
didn't really want to because I'm just
hearing his voice frankly it's like
they're hearing the book goes to
Christmas Past braying away uh but I did
and what was really striking to me was
that he seemed to be living I fell in a
completely delusional world where he
wanted people to believe that there was
no partying and Sunday nothing he was
party to despite the fact that over 80
members of the staff in down the street
got fined by the police for illicit
party
yeah and I think look Boris Johnson it
was really clear from that evidence
session today peers as you say that he
has convinced himself that no rules were
broken in fact he said you know till my
dying day I will believe it was the
right thing to do to go to those leaving
parties all those leaving events of
colleagues during covid and he justified
that by saying that morale was very low
that people were you know in the
building they were starting to struggle
to do their jobs and I think the problem
is the strength of feeling among those
in different careers among nurses among
doctors among people who worked in Care
Homes who will have been shouting at the
television today if they were watching
to say well we felt like that too and we
were not allowed to have drinks we were
not allowed to encourage each other to
keep going I think what was really clear
from that hearing today was that the
Prime Minister the former prime minister
believes that he did nothing wrong he
believes that he can justify every
decision that he made but crucially the
committee did not push him on why
alcohol was present at some of those
events they did not push him about what
happened after he left repeatedly Boris
Johnson said when I was there there were
only 10 people when I was there we were
outside but actually what we know now is
that after he left some of those events
things happened that were not within the
rules all the guidance that could not be
easily Justified and I think the most
tense moments for Boris Johnson today
were when he was pressed on what
advisors had told him whether or not
they had reassured him that guidance was
followed at all times and crucially when
he was asked well what mitigating
factors did you put in place if you
couldn't follow social distancing rules
and he came up with well we didn't touch
each other's pens and I think you could
tell from Harriet Harman who was leading
that committee today when she said well
you did pour drinks for each other
didn't you because we could see it in
the photos you could really feel that
the anger and the tension in that room
Boris Johnson believes he did everything
that he could to keep those things
within the guidance while he was there
I'm not sure that he could say the same
when he wasn't no I could play hogwash
and to use a phrase I will take it till
I die this belief when people were
literally dying in their droves and he
ordered families not to be at Death Beds
made it a criminal offense you know I
know lots of people who lost people or
people like Kate Garrow I work with a
Good Morning Britain whose husband
remains in a in a virtual coma you know
I know other people say goodbye to their
mothers on FaceTime in Care Homes and I
just try to think what must they all be
thinking listening to this because it
wasn't just a one-off this was party
after party after party and it's his
house it's where he was living and the
idea that someone as smart as Boris
Johnson didn't know what was going on is
utter hogwash where does it go this okay
what's the ultimate sanction that's
available to Parliament and what's the
best and worst case scenario for Johnson
well where it goes from here the
committee can recall Boris Johnson if
they feel like they have more questions
I think that's probably unlikely given
that they didn't use all the time they
had allocated to them today they could
ask for more information from some of
the advisors that were said to be giving
him advice on whether all of the rules
and regulations had been stuck to they
may well try and do that they are going
to publish some of the advice that they
had from Sue gray some of the evidence
they took from her because Boris Johnson
said at the start of the committee that
he felt it was unfair that the public
can't see everything that he is relying
on to justify his own position so that's
likely to be published but Piers the
committee has to give Boris Johnson two
weeks notice of their final report which
means that we will at least be two to
three weeks away and I think in reality
probably more like four or five or six
weeks until we see a formal decision you
could hear from Harriet Harman today who
said that Boris Johnson's evidence was
flimsy from others she played a clip
there of Savannah Jenkin who was saying
if Boris Johnson had given the evidence
he gave today in the beginning that
maybe nobody would have been here I
think the tone from around the table was
that they will probably find that he did
mislead the House of Commons but whether
the punishment will go to the full 10
days if it's under 10 days remember that
is that doesn't meet the threshold for a
recall petition in his own seats he
could essentially get a wrap on the
knuckles and continue is this the end of
his political career well running
concurrently today was that vote on the
Stormont break Boris Johnson pretty
Patel Liz truss all voted against but
they couldn't really muster the numbers
to challenge Rishi sunak I think there
is a feeling in Westminster that Boris
Johnson whatever happened today is now
spent as a political force those who'd
already made their mind up will still
feel the same after that Committee
hearing but peers as you say you know
for many people listening today they
don't care about rules they don't care
about guidance what they care about is
that feeling that it just wasn't fair
and I don't think they will have had
their mind changed today well I think
he's lying for his back teeth and it's
the further kicking Matisse to all the
people that he ordered to do one thing
while he didn't know McCann thank you
very much indeed well joining me now is
former advisor Boris Johnson Alex
Crowley former conservative MP Louise
Mensch and by Dr Kathy Gardner who took
the UK government to court over his
decision to discharge hospital patients
into terms at the start of the pandemic
her father Michael died in a care home
in April 2020. let me start with you uh
Dr Kathy
um what did you make of Boris Johnson's
performance today
I wasn't surprised by his continual
ability to to just deny and pretend it
had absolutely nothing to do with him
um it's impossible for him to show
Contrition he really doesn't care about
how he looked to the rest of us all he's
interested in is saving his own skin
yeah I mean that's that's exactly what I
think I think this is all about his
career and saving himself but when he
tries to make us believe that all these
parties party after party after party
that he had no understanding or even an
inkling that any of it broke any rules
when 82 people I think it was got fined
by police for breaking the rules that he
set it's just I I just think it's so
ridiculous to expect us to believe this
it's completely incredible absolutely
impossible to believe it and and the
fact that he thinks that we should is is
just insulting it's insulting to the
intelligence of the majority of the
population yeah I agree um Louise mench
over in New York um I mean you defend
the Interventional Boris time and again
as this is testing even your patients
I think he's very lucky appears that you
weren't sitting on that committee
because I don't think they really landed
a glove on him what we've heard from
your various guests so far is that it's
clear that Boris Johnson himself
believed that he wasn't breaking the
rules now you can say well he should
have known better and maybe that's true
but the question before them isn't party
yet he admits that the rules were broken
and he has said sorry for that the point
is did he deliberately mislead the House
of Commons and I think he made a decent
point when he said if I knew the rules
were being broken would I have sent the
number 10 photographer in to photograph
it and then given it to the press in a
briefing that just doesn't make sense
and I think the fact is he lost his
temper he's going to be upset about that
and you're right basically as he
finished at the moment he is but a week
is a long time in politics and if the
conservatives do really badly in the May
local elections coming up that could
change again Boris Johnson is one of the
great survivors and I don't think this
is the last that we're going to hear he
is but you know in a way you can almost
feel the way the wind's blowing on this
and it's blowing I think much more
favorably for Rishi sunac I think the
budget went down very well I think the
Northern Ireland situation that he seems
to have fixed massive vote win today
Boris just a few straddlers left Boris
Liz trust him if you're against them
you're not really caring I think the
style also leadership that sunac is
bringing and Jeremy Hunt actually where
it's a bit more serious it feels like
there are grown-ups in the room there's
no blatherer there's no Bluster there's
no sleazy like behavior in the
background you put it all together and
you think is there really going to be an
appetite for Boris with all the baggage
and it's the same situation in America
with Trump you know are they actually
and it's a different set of
circumstances but similar kind of vibe
do we want to go back to more of that or
are we wanting to move on to something a
little bit more serious
well everything you say is true peers
but to that I would add the very simple
Point all of that may be true but Rishi
sunak is losing he is still losing he is
still massively down in the polls and
one thing about the conservatives is
that they are very self-interested they
believe they're the right people to run
the country if after all this sensible
thing and it's good progress and I agree
with you about Northern Ireland all of
that's absolutely true but if he
continues to lose you may very well see
Boris Johnson come back as much as you
hate that Prospect let me give you a
little statistic I can't remember the
exact numbers but I think it's something
like that kirstan has now been ahead of
the Tories with his labor party for 400
odd days
um Neil kinnick back in 1992 had
actually been ahead for over 500 days I
think a lot longer and was about the
same rate ahead in the polls 20 odd
percent and kinnick thought he had it in
the bag and an old John Major she came
along and boom he nicked it by being
steady John serious decent guy and
actually they won and they were in a
worse position the Tories at this stage
before that 92 election
through but that's very true but those
of us who are old enough to uh remember
that naming uh no names remember that
kinnick ran a really terrible election
campaign and I don't think uh with the
jeans and he said he tried to portray
himself as down with the kids and all
the rest of it it really wasn't very
good he had a disastrous rally that was
covered everywhere and made him look
frankly stupid I don't think kirst armor
is going to make those same kind of
mistakes all right let me bring an ice
cream you tell him patiently Alex and
you work with Boris Johnson for about
nearly 10 years yeah yeah and he was at
Downing Street with him my question for
you specifically about that
when you watched him today is it
plausible that he can kind of paint a
picture of a busy prime minister running
around and just being completely
oblivious to all this is that actually
plausible given the way Downing Street
operates I recognize some of that I I
absolutely take the point that there are
certain things that he must have known
about and he must have looked at and
thought this isn't a good look if
nothing else but if you think about the
daily schedule of a prime minister right
they have the same number of hours in
the day that you and I have but they
have to do about a hundred more things
they don't do as many hours as you know
probably the nurses and doctors in the
middle of the pandemic no but it's it's
a different it's a different schedule in
the sense that as a prime minister you
are literally shunted from from thing to
thing you're in one meeting then you
leave that meeting and you go off and do
something else and in the middle of two
other things someone will say to you
right could you just go in in there
thank that person then leave again
here's the problem with this and I don't
dispute that I've been in down the
street many times and I've seen how it
works but I also know that if you're
setting Draconian rules for the country
you're literally stopping more than a
handful of people attending funerals the
loved ones who've died
you're stopping people you know doing
all sorts of things just certainly
stopping people in workplaces having
leaving parties and then you try and
have a position well we're the special
ones you know we were working to do all
this stuff for the country so we're
entitled to have a drink entitled to
have a leaving do and not worry too much
about social distancing which was kind
of what his position was today I don't
think the public are going to buy this
because they're going to think well hang
on why is it all right for you to the
virus know that you're the special
people do they give you a special pass
yeah no look and clearly he has paid the
price for that he lost office in fact he
didn't even need to be at this committee
he could have resigned as an MP after he
was removed from Downing Street and none
of this would have needed to happen he's
chosen to stay and he obviously believes
that a he feels he should defend his
position and B he obviously feels he has
some political future because otherwise
he wouldn't have stuck around in the
house do you believe Boris Johnson I
mean he was sacked twice for lying once
as a journalist once as a politician his
record on truth is not good do you
believe him I mean there'll be lots of
people out there they're both personally
and professionally who would say I
wouldn't trust Boris Johnson as far as I
could throw his mob yeah the record
shows that there is some justification
to that right you know he spent his
entire career getting away with things
yes up until this point uh when when he
couldn't get away with it any longer
because he broke the fundamental rule in
public life which is that if you are a
lawmaker you cannot be a law breaker
right what he should have done right at
the beginning of this is he should have
said
okay this was a mistake I'm putting a
stop to this now it should not have
happened it's wrong if it had just done
that I I think he'd probably understand
why he didn't do that I mean if you're
going to be running the country in a
pandemic standing at a Podium every day
and lecturing the public and giving them
you know criminal uh fines for the most
tiny breach of your own rules and then
you're just doing all this with total
impunity why do they need alcohol
Indonesia it must be saving the country
from a pandemic what were you doing
having regular Friday night booze UPS
well what were they doing I mean two
parties on the night print before Prince
Philip's funeral and all this stuff to
me you know the poor Queen I always come
back to that image of the poor Queen
sitting on her own in that mask with
none of the family around her at
Phillip's funeral because she thought it
was the right thing to do where was that
conscience in the Prime Minister the
answer it wasn't there it should have
been there actually those those parties
you referred to he wasn't even at
um but you're right he should have known
they're going on in there of course and
look his name's on the door right so he
has to carry the can not distribution
that at all but I do also think that we
need to look at what the officials were
doing as well because there were a lot
of people working some of them were
warning him about the Optics and what
was going on but he wants us to gloss
over that but he was specifically warned
the Optics of this aren't good but what
about the rest of the officials who knew
that that particular party on the night
of the Duke of edinburgh's funeral was
going on what were they doing I'm not
I'm not saying that Boris is blameless
but that there are a lot more people who
are that's true he was the Prime
Minister the buck stops with him the
question really is whether he should be
allowed back into any form of high
office in this country and I just I just
don't think he should anyway thank you
for coming appreciate it uh thank you to
Louise and thank you to Dr Kathy Gardner
appreciate all of you joining the show
tonight coming next uh find out what
president Trump said about me today
after I sat down for an inclusive
interview with the man tipped to replace
him big rival the Florida governor
rising star of American politics Ron
DeSantis spoiler alert president Trump
wasn't very complimentary about it
foreign
[Music]
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
I'm Sarah Houston his decision that's
questionable not the book frankly it
doesn't do Andrew any favors having this
dripped back into the media I think they
really only care if they come again
Americans love that Royal fairy tale
common ground which is desperately by
the way what the two houses of Windsor
and Montecito need to find is that what
this is about here inviting all his
mates
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
talk about two please welcome downstairs
to Donald Trump is fighting for his
political life as he faces criminal
indictment over hush money he paid to
the porn star Stormy Daniels oh that's
the allegation anyway but that doesn't
seem to be the only thing ruffling the
former president's feathers he wasn't
overly impressed that I sat down with
his current most formidable presidential
rival the wildly successful governor of
Florida Ron DeSantis it's a whole show
that will Air tomorrow night and it'll
make riveting viewing but not even
Donald Trump will make America great
again a group formed of his allies
released a statement earlier saying Ron
DeSantis is lashing out against
President Trump in my interview because
his poll numbers keep falling
unfortunately for DeSantis sitting down
for an interview to bash president Trump
with gun Grabber Piers Morgan won't
solve his issues with Republican voters
well to be clear I don't like grabbing
guns I don't actually like guns at all
it didn't stop there shortly later to my
lack of surprise uh president Trump
himself to do his social media platform
to say while I'm fighting against
radical level lunatics persecutors and
unfair prosecutors who want to destroy
us all Ronda sanctimonious is not
working for the people of Florida as he
should be he's too busy chatting with
the ratings challenge TV hosts in
England desperately trying to rescue his
failing campaign but it's my fault I put
him there then if he's talking about
Rhonda sanctimonious or me there at the
end um but in view of sitting down with
me president Trump you seem to be
suffering from some Amnesia because
you've sat down with me yourself about
40 times including three times when
you're president of the United States so
it couldn't have been that bad uh anyway
Jordan I mean as a former senior
counselor to president Trump from 2017
to 2020 kellyanne come with kellyanne
lovely to see you
hi Paris thanks for having me I always
think it's the high point of flattery if
Donald Trump takes time from his busy
day annihilating everybody else to
launch a personal Savage attack on on me
and thoroughly enjoyed it today and it
wasn't unexpected but behind it I'm
curious what you think of what's going
on here in terms of how he views Ronda
santis and how damaging if at all this
whole legal thing in New York is going
to beat him because it seems the more
that people talk about it the more his
poll numbers seem to be improving
so first things first on the DeSantis
Trump question I got to congratulate you
for getting the governor to sit down and
give a major interview and back to back
then you had a former president perhaps
future president
um make Elevate you on social media so
you're having a really good week Pierce
Morgan uh in terms of DeSantis I mean I
think president Trump has made very
clear he feels that Ron DeSantis should
be more grateful to him for giving him
his endorsement in the primaries when
DeSantis was famously at three percent
showing pictures of his infant and
toddler children uh building walls and
having a Maga onesie on and everything
and then of course campaigning for him
and Ronda Sanchez won the first time
with less than 50 percent of the vote
very small margin but what does Santa's
has done in Florida since is pretty
remarkable he's been an excellent
governor on many accounts and uh and I
think Trump has the Santas where he
wants him right now Trump's poll numbers
are going up the Santas is not a
declared candidate and even you sitting
down for an interview about Rhonda just
as governor of Florida
is forcing him to respond to Donald
Trump so I think all of these candidates
are going to be asked the most popular
common question is going to be Trump I
think so far Senator Tim Scott handled
the question the best I watched him an
interview and he was asked the
legitimate question Pierce so how are
you different from Donald Trump on
policy where do you differ that way we
would think that you're also for an
America First agenda and Senator Scott
said we probably did for very little
that's really the right answer well I it
was interesting it's interesting because
I do think yeah just on that point I
mean I did ask DeSantis that question
let's see what he said let's play the
clip
people have been quite kind of scathing
they've said you're house trained Donald
your diet coke to his full Coke right
you've heard all this stuff what are the
differences between you well I know what
I I know him very well I'm having now
spent time with you I could imagine
identify a few differences but what do
you think of the differences well I mean
I think there's a few things I mean
obviously you know the approach to covid
was different I mean you know I would
have fired somebody like fauci uh I
think that he got way too big for his
britches and I think he did a lot of
damage I also think just in terms of my
approach to leadership you know I get
Personnel in the government who have the
agenda of the people and share our
agenda if you bring your own agenda in
you're gone we're just not going to have
that so the way we run the government I
think is no daily drama focus on the big
picture and put points on the board and
I think that that's something that's
very important I thought that was an
interesting response it wasn't
particularly about policy although
obviously covid he would argue that by
being a must uh much more free in the
way he responded to it in Florida it
turned out to be a smart move but on
this question of how he runs government
there's no doubt is it if Trump gets
back into the White House you were there
last time you were probably one of the
lone voices of calm sanity but all
around you was daily drama and Chaos I
mean there was it's indisputable and I'm
sure that would be the same again Donald
Trump thrives off that kind of stuff so
there you have a clear point of
difference in style DeSantis struck me
as somebody pretty serious-minded he's
not a you know he doesn't go out with
all the the lobby gang he's not a
Washington guy he just wants to do his
job and as he puts it rack up the score
and he's been very successful in Florida
I mean he turned to 30 000 majority
first time he ran for governor tiny
majority to 1.5 million uh arguably the
standout Republican star of the the of
the midterm so he's positioning himself
as a different kind of leader albeit
they pursue a lot of similar policies
yes I don't believe that the Republican
nomination is going to be won or lost
appears on gender on age on Race on
style and not substance people are
drowning economically they're searching
for pockets of air many of them do want
the guy back who they felt made them
more prosperous and safer now there are
plenty of other people who want an
alternative to president Trump even
though his poll numbers have been
increasing this year and he's really put
a bit of distance according to the
political morning consult poll just this
week really put a bit of difference
distance between he and Ron DeSantis and
Republican primary electorate but I I
think for DeSantis he should talk more
about policy taxes regulation his uh any
of his National Security and foreign
policy bonifies because I'll tell you
the world feels like it's on fire right
now in so many places yo Xi Jinping and
Vladimir Putin this budding romance who
haven't ran salivating it Israel you
have them also talking to China it seems
like through Saudi Arabia so many hot
spots Ukraine and Putin
um I think these Governors who have a
great story to tell including DeSantis
are going to need to show that they have
what it takes to be commander-in-chief
and National Security
as well let me just make very clear it
won't matter who the Republican nominee
is for president that person will become
unrecognizable
to the rest of us they will do to Ron
DeSantis or anyone else what they did to
Donald Trump and that that's a given I
also was very surprised he didn't just
say damn straight I can when you asked
DeSantis the question can you beat Joe
Biden he said I think so well
it's interesting because when you read
that it sounds like he was in some
self-doubt when you watch it and I'll
play the clip now it comes over slightly
differently watch this
you think you could beat bud I think so
so you're running them no I didn't say
that I just said I think I could I mean
I think that that's I mean if you look
at Florida it would be harder to be
Biden or Donald Trump workout I don't
know those are two different
well they're all two different people
that's for sure but I think it was a
more emphatic I think so than people
have construed it to be I don't think he
was expressing doubt he was like yeah I
think so yeah I could beat him but it
was interesting it's far lesson that's
right it doesn't say in his eyes I think
he just wanted to make it clear that if
he runs he's running to beat Biden to
the White House he doesn't just see this
as running against Donald Trump
that was one of the smartest things he
said recently electorally he should
transport people into the general
election and say I'm going to run
against Joe Biden and there there's a
significant contrast between as many
contrasts between Joe Biden and Ron
DeSantis but he that road runs through
Donald Trump of course the nomination
but that was smart I guess he's less
emphatic and more hesitant than his
donors and his supporters and those who
insist that he can be by let me tell you
something electability is a fiction I
cannot guarantee who can and cannot win
years before voters exercise their
choice and voice the way you win the
presidency peers is not through
electabilities through electoral college
and you have to go and win those key
States like Pennsylvania Wisconsin
Michigan a whole bunch of them and you
got to start with Florida look does
Santa's in Florida Kim Reynolds in Iowa
Mike dewine in Ohio these are three
states peers that Barack Obama carried
twice that are now ruby red DeSantis and
Kim Reynolds reelected with 19 by 19
Mike dewine reelected by 25 percent of
the vote so the Republican realignment
in some of these states that were
previously purple if not blue as I say
Obama abide and carry them twice has
been truly remarkable okay
how to win Wisconsin Michigan and
Pennsylvania
let me ask you about Donald Trump in
this case the Stormy Daniels Scandal
um
two questions really about this one is
do you think he's going to get indicted
and secondly will that help or hinder
actually his chances of winning back the
White House
well piers in true disclosure I
testified twice before that Manhattan
grand jury in this case and I think I
was called there because of the I was a
campaign manager and clearly this was
not a matter of the campaign it never
crossed my desk and it certainly
wouldn't have broken our stride I was
thinking of one woman at the time in the
fall 2016. her name was Hillary Clinton
not the porn person
um he expects to be indicted he expects
to be arrested and I I can tell you
having sat in the grand jury I think
many of the grand jurors themselves were
paying wrapped attention taking notes
asking questions but it's a very
unfavorable place for Donald Trump and
that the threshold to indict someone is
far lower than to prosecute them and
convict them what I think long term it
helps president Trump in that
electorally speaking people do circle
around him they say you've picked upon
him so much you're picking on me too I
think he's got other legal matters he
needs to still outrun that have nothing
to do with that that case that this D.A
passed on earlier his predecessor passed
on the FEC in this country said no to it
the department
it's a very odd case to bring now it's a
very odd case to bring now to try to get
a misdemeanor books and Records under
New York law to become a felony and
indict the president but there is a
whole bunch of people goes beyond the
Trump base in this country peers who are
so tired of just trying to get Donald
Trump when they feel like we need to get
the economy back in order get energy
Independence back get crime lower get
inflation inflationary prices lower get
the border under control people are very
upset about that it's not just the Trump
base which by the way is 74 million
people to begin with yeah it's a there's
a lot of Truth in that and I I think
making him a martyr over something which
is comparatively trivial like this I
think could be a strategic political
error and I think it is politically
motivated so I wouldn't disagree about
that have you spoken to the president
this week
I have yes I have well can you send him
a message just say look it's the first
anniversary of Piers Morgan uncensored
the show that he said was catching dead
flies I think about nearly a year ago he
was my launch guest interview so rather
than ranting about Ron DeSantis sitting
down with this this guy in England what
about we do the reunion the anniversary
interview
uh president Trump May reunite go to him
yeah pass the message I like it I will
recommend that to him um I certainly
came I'm his warm-up band I suppose and
I I'm sure if you went to Tallahassee
for the interview you'd be willing to go
to Palm Beach for the United Palm Beach
in a heartbeat so I was there last time
that's why we did it in miralaga happy
to get on a plane many times and pass
him on my my very best kellyanne great
to talk to you I will do that sir thank
you pierce all the best all the best but
off the break Prince Harry's drug
confessions in his book could cost him
his U.S visa will they kick him out and
if they do where will he go you don't
want him back we'll debate that next
[Music]
pop the kettle on this is the royalty
I'm Sarah Houston his decision that's
questionable not the book pranked it
doesn't do Andrew any favors having this
dripped back into the media I think they
really only care if they come again
Americans love that Royal fairy tale
common ground which is desperately by
the way what the two houses of Windsor
and Montecito need to find is that what
this is about here inviting all his
mates
[__]
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back I'm with my talk TV
business correspondent presenter
Lockwood talked to be contributor Esther
Krakow and Daily Mirror Associated to
Kevin guy was to [__] on TV but we let
him come in every now and again
um give me uh two two big blondes out
there battling away to save their
careers Boris Johnson is he done or will
he wriggle off the hook again now I
think the uh Chris piglets uh for it
this time do you I think they'll find
him guilty of recklessly misleading
Parliament and what happens to him then
then they decide the punishment I
suspect they won't press the nuclear
button and make it 10 days because that
would trigger a potential by-election in
Oxbridge so you either you get him to
apologize to the house do you give him a
suspension of several days five days
meanwhile his successor after the one we
forget about trust uh Richardson
squirreled out on a good date of very
bad and you squirrel that his tax
returns today now when I interviewed him
at Downing Street uh several weeks ago
he said they're going to come soon and
he did deliver them I've got to say I
wasn't massively surprised in the way
some people have been that he pays a lot
of tax particularly on capital gains on
his Investments the guy is stinking rich
as I said to him yeah I'm going to count
you on that though he doesn't pay that
much tax when you consider he only paid
around a quarter of his income in tax
around 21 it's about the same as a nurse
in this country he made close to 1.9
million over the course of a year and
then only around 430 000 of that went
out in tax payments you're right he did
make a lot of money through capital
gains in Beth from his Investments
um but a lot of his money that he's
making is from his U.S funds overseas
he's not actually probably why are we so
obsessed with it being a problem we have
a prime minister who's wealthy I mean
you were telling me earlier tell me
about is this Singapore yes Singapore so
Singapore the Prime Minister makes 2.2
million US dollars a year off as a
salary plus bonus now they're very clear
about this we can't make apples and
oranges comparisons because Asian
governance models wouldn't work in the
UK but they're clear on why they pay
their ministers millions in salaries
they say it encourages good performance
it encourages attraction of the best
candidates and it tamps down on
corruption second jobs and lobbying
thank you I made this point I said MP
salary needs to be quadrupled and to be
in the government you need to be paid
five times higher because we need to
draw the best talent because I do think
the caliber of politicians we have now
is so Dreadful because no decent person
would want to be be a boss I sort of
agree Kevin I actually I know you won't
but I'm not sure there's a correlation
between High earnings and the quality
Bank on minimum wage
tax tax return one I think it makes the
case for reform a couple of games and
tax now at least the same as income
secondary yeah in a cost living crisis
the problem for sunac and he knows this
is he just seems to be out of touch
because he is insulated he's building a
swimming but then what do you want when
families so you can only be prime
minister and the cost of living crisis
if you're completely is the richest by
the way we saw with Boris Johnson when
he ran short of cash what happens when a
prime minister runs short of cash they
start doing stuff they shouldn't be
doing getting dodgy you know what's
weird back in the day you would
celebrate someone like Rishi sunai
because he's a brown man that's made a
huge success in himself in in Britain
but now that he's prime minister you're
saying he's out of touch because he has
two things by the way one is and his
wife told me that when she was very
young they had nothing exactly her
father famous self-made billionaire in
India it wasn't all just handed so the
air the air refs is shaking the charity
people who are self-made there is a
problem yes we do yes
do you get any sense then when you
interview Trump or DeSantis because U.S
leaders and politicians they rake in
hundreds of millions in donations
they're self-made and Wealthy as well do
you think that makes them effective at
governing or are they out of touch I
think that DeSantis has proven in
Florida that actually it's got nothing
to do with it what people want I think
and they see in him certainly I was
quite impressed by them I have to say
not in all his policies some of which
I'll take issue with but and his
leadership style very firm very data
driven and very much get the score on
the board get stuff done that's what
people led to me to do and it's popular
I'm gonna say everywhere I went in
Florida they loved the centers and I
love it in terms of transparency about
earnings the point Kevin's making I
think Britain has an issue with very
wealthy people in power they want to see
transparency of those tax returns David
Cameron Chancellor George Osborne as
well released a summary of His tax I
haven't seen any labor leaders required
to release those details got a few Bobs
stashed away
no look they're they're wealthy they're
okay comfortable let's move on to um to
someone else who's got a lot of money
um but I definitely don't want running
the high office which is our friend
Prince Harry now he's got himself into a
bit of a bind here and I know I know why
this is what he said to Tom Bradley at
itm
there's a fair amount of drugs marijuana
magic mushrooms cocaine I mean that's
gonna surprise people but important to
acknowledge
well maybe it is but what he didn't
factor into his confession particularly
about drug taking in America is he's not
an American citizen so in a state like
California a lot of Brits might go there
and think oh it's legal to be seen
smoking split it's not unless you're an
American citizen the federal law for the
whole country which would apply to
non-citizens is that it's illegal so
he's admitted breaking the law that
could trigger a review of his Visa
status absolutely and you know the
argument is he's not a threat to the
country so that shouldn't affect him too
much but it just shows he's he's a very
stupid man because there's so many
instances I mean one of the things that
he's been going I think imagine
mushrooms
but the thing is he's been complaining
with that he's his legal case with a
home office is that he hasn't he doesn't
receive enough security because of his
status well you know one thing you don't
help yourself when you talk about your
Taliban kill count in your book right he
is his Own Worst Enemy and this is
another thing that just shows how really
short-sighted he is as an individual
yeah I'm sure other people have written
about drug use in order have that's
historic drug use I don't think I don't
think the stuff he talks about when he's
a teenager is a problem the problem is
this was current in America taking magic
I remember in California while he's been
there in the last year I remember
Nigella Lawson being taken off the
flight in 2014 to the US after she was
George Michael George Michael told me he
couldn't go back to America because
every time he did they put him in a room
but she had just been pictured on the
front of the Sunday people it was with
Charles sarchio then take it seriously
pulling her nose now she hadn't she
hadn't admitted to drug taking or
anything but there was a suspicion they
took her off normally it's if you then
trigger like yeah you're gonna drink
driving a fence or you get some criminal
offense then it really comes into play
and you can literally have your Visa
ripped up and thrown out go take a break
hold whatever you're about to tell me
Rosanna I'm I'm absolutely desperate to
hear it you sounded so pumped up for it
coming next we'll look uh to my excuse
me to be with thoroughly Governor Ron
DeSantis it's a really interesting room
the guy who might who might in 2024 be
the new president of the United States
talking about that after break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
this is the royal tea I'm Sarah Houston
his decision that's questionable not the
book frankly it doesn't do Andrew any
favors having this dripped back into the
media I think they really only care if
they come again Americans love that
Royal fairy tale common ground which is
desperately by the way what the two
houses of Windsor and Montecito need to
find is that what this is about here
inviting all his mates
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
well coming up on the talk we'll be
delving into the key moments from Boris
Johnson's brutal grilling by MPS over
partygate plus Prince Harry's US Visa
could be in Jeopardy thanks to those
Revelations about his drug taking and
are you avoiding your morning commute
over fears of germs we're discussing all
of that and much more at nine
you made a fatal error in your
relationship with that Donald Trump you
got too popular
they've said you're house trained Donald
your diet coke to his full coat you're a
wannabe autograph you're the Genghis
Khan of social issues ignorant racist a
gaping leap I criticized you there you
go what's your view of Putin I think he
is a war criminal
I think so so you took the knee Governor
yeah yeah that's the only time I take it
foreign
[Music]
look at some of the coverage it's been
getting already
also in the news this morning Governor
Ron DeSantis hinting at what his
political future may be and this
sit-down interview with Piers Morgan
Governor Ronda Santa says well he hasn't
made a final decision on running for
president he says he could be President
Joe Biden Governor Ron DeSantis
delivered his strongest response yet to
Trump's attacks in a new Piers Morgan
interview Ron DeSantis in a new Fox
Nation interview telling Piers Morgan if
I were to run I'm running against Biden
Florida Governor sat down for a
wide-ranging interview with Pierce
Morgan according to the British
broadcaster de Santa slammed Trump over
his character failings chaotic
leadership style and his handling of the
covid pandemic
and the New York Post did uh well the
whole front page which a certainly
rattle cages that's what's prompted the
response from Trump so we've got to hear
there we go Ron it's Don
um that's not Don of the [__] that's me
um anyway he's got a lot of people going
um Rosetta Donald Trump what's
incredible is that despite all the legal
problems the porn stars the this the
that the other he is on the verge
according to the polls of potentially
making one of the all-time great
comebacks yeah depending on which poll
you look at he already has at this point
proceedings he's galvanizing his base
Point using his criminal proceedings
this Manhattan indictment about his
Stormy Daniels case which you've already
discussed at length with kellyanne
earlier in the show but it it it it just
is extraordinary that DeSantis can't
grab that Mega base from Trump well it's
hard for him you know because what he
does uh Esther he he just you know he's
a big beast Trump and he he comes after
people and it's very hard remember what
he did to Jeb Bush and all the others
you know low energy gem Little Marco
Rubio he gives them these tanks I'm not
sure de sanctimonious worked it's too
long yeah it's too long the problem with
Trump is he makes all the other
candidates rotate in his orbit because
he is the gravitational force
effectively and when you're when you're
running a campaign well primary that is
effectively your Kryptonite because you
have to have some sort of attention and
you can't really kind of play nice with
Trump and then when you hook no well
that's why I think the Santa's real
smart to finally get on the front foot a
bit you can't just keep taking it he was
funny too about the sanctimonious
nickname just listen to this
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving you so far is it Ron
Ronda sanctimonious or meatball rock
well I can't even he went off meatball
wrong I can't uh I don't know how to
spell the sanctimonious I don't really
know what it means but I you know I kind
of like it's long it's got a lot of
valve I mean so we'll go with that
that's fine you know you can call me you
can call me whatever you want I mean
just as long as you you know also call
me a winner because that's what we've
been able to do in Florida has put a lot
of points on the board and and really
take the state to the next level I
thought that was a smart response a
laughing off the nickname but reminding
people he is a big winner I mean there's
midterm most of Trump's Trump's picks
lost or did badly DeSantis absolutely
rocketed now he's behind in the polls
but he's about the same place that Trump
was against Hillary Clinton yeah he's
got to get in the game but yeah he has
to you're going to get in the game but
you're right he turned it turn it round
he laughed at himself people like that
and he used it say he's a winner and
Trump had a terrible midterm if I am Joe
Biden and the Democrat
would be absolutely the pig yes the
ground has shifted under Trump and
arguably under Boris under the covid and
other wars in the last few years and the
way politics is run and the way people
vote is different now we know what's
powerful Esther Charisma and whether you
like Trump or not he's got unbelievable
Charisma and I always say that the weird
thing about him he's got the thinnest
skin imaginable yeah and so I've had a
load of statements for him today calling
me ratings challenge a gun Grabber and
all the rest of it oblivious effect he
also did loads of videos with me but he
also has the thickest skin and that's an
amazing quality for a presidential
candidate when all the heat comes he can
soak it up like no one I've seen and
dish it up but there is there is a
possibility in an alternative universe
that people could Tire of this so if
inflation keeps going up if you know the
issues with the economy and with the
energy you know keep hampering on this
there is going to be a shifting point
where people think you want someone
serious handling this and I think that's
something that could really help you
understand exactly DeSantis is a serious
I mean people will see tomorrow night I
recommend watching it it's in Tim as
you've never seen him and he's also very
emotional stuff about his wife who just
had breast cancer survived that uh last
year his sister died in London of a
pulmonary embolism ages 30. wow which
was an awful time in his family's life
so well worth watching thank you pack
great to see you tomorrow night Ron
DeSantis the man who would be president
one on one for the hour whatever you're
up to Keep It Uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
I'm Sarah Houston his decision that's
questionable not the book pranked it
doesn't do Andrew any favors having this
dripped back into the media I think they
really only care if they come again
Americans love that Royal fairy tale
common ground which is desperately by
the way what the two houses of Windsor
and Montecito need to find is that what
this is about here inviting all his
mates
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it